early humans communicated with pictures
and markings painted on cave walls and
began to gradually work out symbols as
these markings spread and were
understood and accepted then you had the
widespread transmission of ideas we can
see the very early days of this
communication in the Ice Age caves of El
Castillo we live in this modern world
hugely interconnected globally based in
large part on our ability to communicate
graphically everything from like binary
coding computers to texting and we take
them for granted but I think what's so
easy to forget is that if you go back
far enough in time you will actually get
to a point where there was no graphic
communication where somebody had to
invent it for the very first time
[Music]
think about the moment that moment when
somebody picked up probably a tool and
made an engraved mark in some sort of
objects
and with that simple little stroke of a
tool completely changed our entire
ability to communicate so this is
actually a child hand and it's not just
anywhere it's in the depths of the cave
so this tells us it wasn't just adults
coming down here
they brought their kids with them which
really suggests that for them these
caves weren't scary places
in La Paz yoga cave is one of those rare
animals we're looking at a bison which
if you look to see actual detail the
horror in the eyes in the perky little
tail it's simple in many ways but so
sophisticated in others and it dates to
about probably about twenty five
thousand years ago or so communicating
with others has been an important part
of why people have scratched things on
rocks and made made drawings you can
look at these things and imagine very
clearly what it must have been like to
bend those people on the hunt it's the
kind of time travel that allows you to
step into another period or another
place if you've been into one of these
caves into one of the chambers and the
lights are turned off the silence is
really profound
they could play tricks with lights to
make animals move and so on was all
performance but performance had a
purpose the purpose was to reinforce the
relationship with the forces of the
supernatural world with the animals and
the world that surrounded you
well coffee I guess many things that
make it very special case but to me one
of the most important is actually the
series of fines right up here on this
wall it's known as the laplacian
inscription and it's literally one is
the only places in the whole of ICG
earth that we have an entire row of
geometric signs that are lined up and
organized and it actually appeared to be
related to each other we're certainly
not talking about writing yet yes but
certainly has a writing like look to it
but it's a one-off this is the only
place we ever find this this is them
starting to experiment they're starting
to play around with organizing the fun
even if it's not truly writing it's an
incredibly important clue to
understanding where and how graphic
communication really started coming
together
[Music]